hi I'm Doug Barrett from the ellenwood
ldi store and i'm here to talk today on
the proper ballasting of the tractor and
the proper air inflation of the tires
what we have we're wanting to maintain a
two to four percent slip when setting up
our tractor for the proper demo so to do
that we've got to go in and we've got to
get our air pressure set properly from
tire to tire and also on the back the
proper inflation will basically put
three bars on the ground solid on the
ground that will be what you look
forward and you can adjust from that by
whatever piece of equipment that you've
got on the back of the attractor the
other thing will have will be proper
ballasting which is going to be our
weight issues we're going to have weight
on the inside of our duels and we can
set different weights for that plus
we'll have weights on the front of the
tractor and we can do that
[Music]